back baby whoa oh we in it we're rolling
all right we're rolling baby keep them
doggies going raw
hide
this is these drinks are killing me dude
i know oh man oh man mark you have a fan
here who just
thanked you for doing this podcast by
sending you
uh a lagavelan 16. this is no joke this
is a great bottle maybe one of the best
scotches on the planet thank you
jared at is it meet jerry podcast get
jerry on get jerry on okay so this is
part of the bar now we gotta we gotta
wow
that is high-end stuff right there petey
as hell smokey good scotch so petey
love it pete best amy schumer would have
that [ __ ] in the in the dressing room oh
you got that right oh that's where i
fell in love with this 16 year old girl
oh my god mark look at this we got some
new orleans beer koozies oh wow
i love you i love jesus new orleans is
for livers that's clever
swamp ass that's fun uh-huh who sent
that
give a shout out to the uh proprietor
there this is from dirty coast press
from new orleans oh they make hats and
stuff this guy's awesome thank you dirty
coach a lot of new orleans stuff look at
all this knowledge stuff you might want
to take some of this home yeah yeah we
just had ida parents are fine they lo
they still have no power by the way
there oh no yeah how are they doing
appropriating the amish they're playing
scrabble and reading by the fire they're
the candle lit
damn it's funny how no power is romantic
we're lit too but we got power still you
got that right
yeah power is romantic yeah it's like
horse and buggy candlelight
fireplace
i don't know who the hell sent us this
tutus pantry is that a candle
can pineapple butter
maui onion chili pepper jelly
holy [ __ ] hold on let's get some matches
in here you got any you got a lighter
there is this a i don't think there's a
candle this looks like jelly dude oh
even worse
oh [ __ ] you're not you're not joking ooh
this is badass the waldorf restoria bar
book
what
this is this is a part of the bar wow
we got a [ __ ] bar here man what do
you say hell yeah the waldorf story a
bar book what are we supposed to do with
this pineapple butter this is from maui
by the way i don't know let's get some
toast we'll get some let's get some
toast in studio and have it before we
drink so we're not always so [ __ ] up
i heard i was watching a bourdain
episode the other day and there was a
great quote where he said uh
one of his friends he's in london one of
his friends they're they're drinking and
eating around the table and he goes
there's an old quote uh no one ever got
old around the dinner table oh
isn't that great a great equalizer the
great leveler the dinner table also you
don't get old if you kill yourself
well you know what matt we were trying
not to go there oh thank you hemingway
chocolate soldier plymouth gin or
nicholson london dry gin
bonol quinquica aperitif or dubonnet i
don't know what that is and half an
ounce fresh lime juice a chocolate
soldier oh
i like that good porn
all right these are you sound good a
charlie chaplin a a one ounce rothman
and winter orchard apricot liqueur one
ounce plymouth aloe gin and one ounce
one ounce fresh lime juice yes have you
heard of that
no but i love it it sounds great by the
way charlie chaplin not american not
jewish no he is jewish not american i
don't think he's jewish where is he i
don't think he's jewish either where is
he from england english
married a fourteen-year-old yeah would
you
yes no oh no that's brutal that's too
young in that conversation
but he was young oh my god can you
imagine how boring a 14 year old would
be ah
yeah
yeah jesus i mean like i don't want to
hang out with a 14 year old otherwise
exactly i think i want to [ __ ] marry
a 14 i got it oh my god and they're not
attractive sexually they're going
through puberty
i mean that isn't even hot 14 is too
young to be hot even
like ghosts 18 19 i get it it's still cr
i'm even gonna go i get it i think
it's funny it's funny i was watching
manhattan again not too long ago woody
allen i mean look it's a great movie but
you had the end of that i was talking to
my buddy ron on hershberg and he was
like dude that movie is like a romantic
comedy for pedophiles
he said like basically the only thing is
like i wasn't mature enough to make it
work with a child
right that's the takeaway from the movie
you're like damn that's a pretty damn
good point i think it won an oscar
it must have won so it was my best
picture it's gorgeous it's a gorgeous
movie
are you taking a sip of that i'm taking
a little piece of butter here i want to
see what pineapple butter is all about i
dipped the doughnut in it but the
doughnut was too overpowering
subtle
a very buttery dude that's [ __ ] good
that is really good i could eat that
more to see guys join the patreon right
now at patreon.com we might be drunk get
on the after party i think i just broke
this
there you go
you get emails tell us your wrecks your
jokes your drinks we'll open boxes
you're missing out folks all the good
stuff's on the patreon tell a friend